[Music]
let me understand how you get this part
in in New Jack city I'd I'm in the men's
room at some Club and somebody's talking
[ __ ] to me I'm in this stall right and
somebody talking [ __ ] to me and I'm just
like look man if they could put me under
a microscope and find one molecule or me
to gave a [ __ ] then maybe they could
angle me but they can't so they can't
[ __ ] with me you showed that in the
bathroom to your friend no this is some
random [ __ ] talking to me over
the toilet then I go in other words you
didn't know you were auditioning at the
time Mario Van Peebles is directed a
movie was in there and he said whoever
[ __ ] said that is the star of my
movie so I come out at my laughter I
wipe my ass and Mario says I so that now
I'm in the club and Mario walks up to me
and eat with that Hollywood [ __ ]
what's Hollywood [ __ ] Hollywood
[ __ ] is when people see you and they
say we should work right and I know it's
going nowhere what was [ __ ] you but
you could call me like just because
we're in this party doesn't mean we
gotta act like we're gonna be friends
right [ __ ] you right so you're angry
with it yeah well you know people do you
Adam music oh yeah we should record my
number you can call me you know why now
cuz I'm standing for anything I'm punch
you in the face so so he says to me you
should be in my movie I'm like okay you
just want to talk to these girls right I
know the girl you're trying to impress I
won by tell him you make movies right
right her name is this and her name is
this and her name is this and I kept it
moving he said now call me tomorrow
so I called and they were acting it was
one of brothers and they like yeah we
want you to come over here and read for
this movie and I was like too real so I
went there and I looked at the script
they say you're gonna read for Scottie
the cop well not even the cop first
Howard I was just like yo this is all
the lines this is the whole movie I
thought it was a part like I'm not an
actor you could do it no no I can't do
wait a minute he's got dreads I got a
perm you could do it I'm like the
[ __ ] policeman like I got album
called og
you could do it don't pass up this
opportunity
I'm scared and I hear it I was scared I
called my friends I called my homies
yo man they want me to be a police word
can I be in the movie like you know like
I got a problem with that
I'm not even my boys in jail I'm like
man I look I know you stuff I know but
look I just got an offer to be in a
movie
you know plated playing poli free word
if I was out could I be in the movie I
can get like thanks so so far all the
support yeah the girls that like to get
my hair done the ladies at my shop a
good Fred's in the hood they would like
well [ __ ] if you don't take this part
use a sucker and Ike we know to shoot a
kind of [ __ ] that's gonna keep
it 100 and stay you know they say 100
back then but nothing real and stay true
to the hood no matter how big you get
you got to do this ice you can act you
act for us every day [ __ ] stop playing
just go in there and do the damn movie
or don't come back to the shop yeah
because we're just opportunities like
this in life no one